so what we have depicted this diagram is
the business cycle that we have looked
at in other videos this horizontal axis
is time vertical axis is real GDP what
we see in this dark blue color you can
view that as full employment output at
different points in time and you can see
that it is growing so this economy is
experiencing economic growth maybe its
population is increasing they're getting
more productive maybe with better
education or with better technology but
we know that real economies don't just
have this nice clean economic growth
they tend to cycle around their full
employment output that times when
they're above the trend line like right
over here you have a positive output gap
so this is a positive output gap at that
point right over there and you can also
have negative output gaps we also talked
in other videos about fiscal policy
these are the tools that governments
might use in order to close these output
gaps for example when you have a
positive output gap a government might
be afraid that things are overheating
maybe they're afraid of inflation they
might have contractionary fiscal policy
they might try to do something for that
moment in time to bring to close that
gap a little bit more likely when there
is a negative output gap and people are
out of work the government say hey I
want let's let's pass a stimulus package
explicitly to try to close this gap
let's lower taxes let's increase
government spending that type of fiscal
policy where the government is doing
something special for that circumstance
in order to close that output gap that
is discretionary discretionary fiscal
policies that the discretion of the
government to do it but we're going to
focus on in this video our automatic
stabilizers these are things that people
don't have to take special action based
on the circumstances in order for them
to help smooth out the business cycle so
automatic stabilizers so what are
examples of automatic stabilizers so one
common one is taxes so pause this video
for a second and think about how do
taxes help smooth out these fluctuations
so let's think about what's
happening at a part of the business
cycle where the economy is expanding
let's say right over there or let's say
right over here what would be happening
with taxes well in these realities with
this positive output gap you could
imagine four people's incomes are going
to get higher and higher corporate
profits are going to be more and more
and so our change in taxes is going to
be positive and not only is it going to
be positive not only your tax is going
to increase in absolute dollar terms but
they're probably going to grow at a
faster rate than the economy why is that
when the economy turns positive when you
start expanding more more and more
corporations are going to become
profitable if you think about personal
income taxes below certain incomes in a
lot of countries you don't even have to
pay income taxes and that for every
incremental dollar or every incremental
$10,000 the tax rate on that incremental
chunk could go up and so that's why the
absolute dollar amount of taxes will
likely increase as a faster rate than
the actual economic growth and let's
think about the other scenario let's
think about what taxes do when we are in
a recession so let's say we pick that
place right over there well in this
situation corporate profits are going to
be lower in fact some corporation is
going to come unprofitable in which case
they wouldn't pay corporate taxes people
are gonna make less and less money so
your change in taxes here is going to be
likely to be negative and once again
your rate of decrease in taxes is likely
to be greater than your great in
decrease of real GDP the tax multiplier
is negative and so it might smooth out
the curve a little bit now another
example of an automatic stabilizer would
be things like welfare payments or
unemployment insurance why would these
be automatic stabilizers well when times
are good when you have this positive
output gap fewer and fewer people are
going to need welfare or need they're
going to need unemployment payments and
so in that world that is like a decrease
in government spending the government's
not going to have to pay for these
benefits and so decrease in government
spending
that's contractionary and so that will
help smooth out the curve a little bit
and once again when we have are when we
when we go
to our recession and then when we
started having our negative output gaps
more people are going to be on welfare
more people are going to need their
unemployment benefits and so that's
going to increase government spending
which might with them with the
multiplier smooth out this curve a
little bit and so the big takeaway is is
when the government does something
explicitly for the time that they are in
in order to smooth out the curve that's
discretionary fiscal policy but you
might have things in the system the
existing tax policy existing laws around
welfare or unemployment insurance or
other benefits that might have an effect
of regardless of where we are on the
business cycle they are a damp to have a
dampening effect they try to they would
smooth out these oscillations a little
more they would be automatic stabilizers